my apology
America's most loved newsman just got
caught in a lie and boy are people
reacting helicopter we were traveling in
was forced down after being hit by an
RPG NBC News's Bryan Williams apologized
on Wednesday for claiming that he had
been in a US military helicopter that
was shot down by RPG fire in the early
days of the Iraq war a story he's been
telling for many years and as recently
as last week things changed this week
when military newspaper
stars-and-stripes sets the record
straight a helicopter was shot down but
Williams wasn't in it or anywhere near
it he wasn't a separate one that arrived
in the area about an hour later I made a
mistake in recalling the events of 12
years ago oh right that wasn't me that
was shot down in a helicopter Williams
didn't actually report he was shot down
back in 2003 but as the years went by
his story got a bit more elaborate two
of our four helicopters were hit by
ground fire including the one I was in
journalists and non journalists alike
slammed the star anchor on Twitter like
Jillian Keenan who said this time it
really is about ethics and journalism
CNN's brian Stelter tweeted at the end
of the day a lot of doubt that Brian
Williams could have innocently
misremembered an RPG attack in Iraq and
Liliana Segura said troubled by this
Brian Williams news what if other
reporting around the Iraq invasion was a
lie some looked at the bigger picture
like Rob Delaney who said can't quite
remember what it was but I seem to
recall hearing bigger lies about Iraq
than this Brian Williams one hmm
it'll come to me others took a more
humorous tone with the hashtag Brian
Williams memories Jeremy Scahill joked
correction I didn't storm the beach at
Normandy
I just had a friend named Norman and in
another tweet I said Martin do you dream
he said yes I said we'll tell the folks
about your dream but jokes aside many
are wondering where his career goes from
here if journalists who are entrusted by
the public to report the truth fail at
doing so should they be allowed to
continue in their roles what do you
think